Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu 28. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe rund um Wissenschaft, rund um wissenschaftliche Themen, wissenschaftliche Fragen. Themen, die auf die Bedeutung der Wissenschaft als solche hinterfragen, teilweise auch die Methoden. Und zuletzt hatten wir ja eine verstärkte Themendichte im Bereich Nachhaltigkeit und ich vermute, in diesen Bereich werden wir auch heute wieder reingrätschen, während wir uns einfach auch einen bestimmten Forschungsbereich mal etwas genauer anschauen, der sonst nicht so im Mittelpunkt steht. Heute geht es um den Sumpf. Um Moore, um sehr alte ökologische Strukturen. Und um darüber ausführlich zu sprechen, begrüße ich Dr. Hans Joosten, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herr Joosten, Sie sind Moorforscher, kann man das so sagen?
Ja darf man sagen.
Darf man sagen, okay dann trau ich mich das jetzt einfach mal. Das heißt das Moor, Moorlandschaften, alles was so mit feuchtem Boden zu tun hat, das bestimmt nahezu 100% Ihrer Tätigkeit, kann man das so sagen?
Ja im weitesten Sinne. Ich gucke nicht nur nach Boden, aber das ganze Umfeld gehört dazu.
Es gibt auch diesen schönen Namen der Paläoökologie. Das ist dann auch glaube ich die offizielle Beschreibung Ihrer Lehrtätigkeit an der Universität in Greifswald?
Ja die Beschreibung ist Moorkunde und Paläoökologie. Das sind eigentlich zwei getrennte Sachen, die eigentlich auch viel miteinander zu tun haben. Vielleicht am besten zu erklären, die Paläoökologie ist die Ökologie der Vergangenheit und um die Vergangenheit zu kennen braucht man natürlich Archive, wo Informationen über die Vergangenheit abgelegt sind. Und diese Archive sind oft Moore. Moore sind Ökosysteme, wobei die pflanzliche Produktivität größer ist als die Zersetzung nachher. Die meisten Ökosysteme, die wir kennen, sind in einem bestimmten Gleichgewicht. Langfristig bauen die genau so viel ab, als dass sie produzieren. Moore machen das nicht. Moore produzieren mehr als abgebaut wird. Und infolgedessen lagert sich Schicht nach Schicht organisches Material ab.
Das bedeutet, ein Moor wächst als Landschaft und diese Schichten werden natürlich, wenn man sie anguckt, in der heutigen Geschichte, sind sie eigentlich jünger, indem sie höher sind. Also wenn wir ein Moor haben und wir graben dort in der Tiefe, wir bohren dort und wir holen dort Material raus, dann können wir Informationen kriegen aus der Vergangenheit. Unsere Moore hier in Deutschland sind weitestgehend angefangen zu wachsen, nachdem die Eiszeit fast zu Ende war. Natürlich müssen die Gletscher sich zurückgezogen haben und in dieser Landschaft sind dann oft feuchte Stellen, Moore gewachsen und das bedeutet, dass wir in vielen Mooren Informationen finden von Ende letzter Eiszeit bis hin zu der heutigen Situation, wenn das Moor weiter gewachsen ist.
So Moor lagert natürlich die Pflanzenreste ab, die dort früher gewachsen sind, die sind dann wohl zum Teil abgebaut, und schwierig zu erkennen, deshalb muss man einfach ein Spezialist sein. Aber außerdem fangen die Moore auch allerhand Sachen ein, die von draußen kommen. Eine ganz wichtige Gruppe von Substanzen sind die Staubmehlkörner, die Pollen, wie wir die nennen. Die werden massivst produziert, was wir jetzt im Frühling natürlich auch gut spüren.
Mit Allergien und allem.
Mit Allergien und allem. Und ich sage mal, auf jeden Quadratzentimeter fallen pro Jahr 15.000 Pollenkörner. Das bedeutet, wenn wir die aus dem Torf holen und wir mittels Mikroskop in der Lage sind, diese Staubmehlkörner zurückzubestimmen, was für Pflanzenarten sie gebildet haben, können wir auf diese Weise die Vegetation in der Vergangenheit rekonstruieren. Auf diese Weise, mittels der Vegetation, aber auch auf andere Wiese, mittels stabiler Isotope, können wir auch Informationen kriegen über die Klimaentwicklung. Und natürlich die ganze Landschaftsentwicklung, wie die von Menschen geprägt wird, wird darin auch festgelegt. In dem Moment, wo die Menschen anfangen, Landwirtschaft zu betreiben, dann sieht man, dass die Wälder teilweise verschwinden. Man sieht neue Gewächse erscheinen, die Kulturgewächse. Man sieht auch Unkräuter, die damit assoziiert sind und so weiter.
Und das liegt alles in Mooren abgelagert und das ist eigentlich die Verbindung zwischen Mooren als wachsende Ökosysteme und Paläoökologie, die aus der Gegenwart versucht, die Vergangenheit zu rekonstruieren.
Das heißt die Moore sind im Prinzip so die ökologischen Geschichtsbücher, dort kann man wirklich bis weit in die Vergangenheit zurückblicken und das steht so im Mittelpunkt?
Ja.
Wir wollen da gleich nochmal ganz viel drüber reden. Mich würde vorher nochmal ein bisschen interessieren, wie Sie eigentlich zu diesem Thema gekommen sind. Was ist denn so Ihr persönlicher Weg in die Wissenschaft, und vor allem konkret in die Moorforschung gewesen, warum hat Sie das interessiert, wieso ist es dazu gekommen?
Das ist zum Teil Zufall und zum Teil vorgegeben sozusagen. Ich bin im Moor geboren, um es so zu sagen.
Wo?
Ich bin am Rand eines Moores geboren im Südosten der Niederlande und wir hatten innerhalb fünf Kilometer von unserem Haus 40% aller Hochmoorreste der Niederlande liegen. Das war für mich eigentlich nichts besonderes. Das hat mich nicht dahin geführt, um Moorforscher zu werden.
Weil war ja normal oder?
Das ist so normal, das tut man nicht.
Man kommt aus dem Haus raus, Moore.
Ja. So das ist nichts. Man wollte doch etwas besonderes tun. Ich wollte eigentlich Verhaltensforscher werden. Tierverhaltensforscher. Ethologie, so was wie Tiere in ihrem Verhalten zu verstehen, um somit Menschen besser zu verstehen. Aber dann sind da solche Zufälle, man geht zur Uni und dann denk ich, ja da gab es noch keine Studienrichtung so. Aber ich dachte, ich kaufe mal ein Buch darüber und das Buch ist niemals angekommen. Das ist der Zufall. Und dann gab es eigentlich allerhand Gründe, weil ich war ja gesellschaftlich, politisch aktiv geworden in meiner Gegend und dann war es wohl bequem, um meine Diplomarbeit auch in dieser Gegend zu schreiben, weil dann war ich nah an dem, wo die Arbeit geschehen würde. Und dann habe ich angefangen, dort im Moor meine erste Diplomarbeit zu machen und das hat mich dann wohl gegriffen.
Und dann dachte ich nach einer Weile, als ich 19/20 Jahre alt war oder 21 dachte ich, man muss doch etwas tun im Leben. Und wenn man etwas gut machen will, dann muss man sich eigentlich einigermaßen konzentrieren und lass ich einfach mal Moore tun. Und es hat sich für mich gezeigt, ich denke das ist bei jeder Wissenschaft so, wenn man sich darin vertieft ist das so interessant, dass man weitergeht. Ich habe wohl einen Forschergeist, ich bin wohl neugierig, ich will wissen, wie was funktioniert. Und bei Mooren kamen dann doch diese Interessen zusammen, die ich hatte, ich war auch stark interessiert in Geschichte. Sozial-ökonomische Geschichte und auch die Interferenzen zwischen Landschaft und Mensch, wie Menschen umgehen mit den Landschaften. Ich war interessiert in Verhalten und dann zeigte sich, dass auch die Moore Exponenten waren von allen diesen Aspekten.
In Moore, sicher bei uns in der Gegend, das sind ich sage mal natürliche Ökosysteme, die unglaublich stark übergeprägt sind von Menschen. Die meisten Sachen, die wir hier sehen, die wir als Schutzgebiete würdigen und staunen, dass das so wilde Natur ist, das sind tote Leichen. Wir haben keine Idee, wie ein Moor aussehen muss. Die Leute hier in Westeuropa haben keine Idee, was ein Moor ist, weil es das nicht mehr gibt. Durch die Rekonstruktion aus der Vergangenheit kriegt man eine bessere Idee. Und man geht natürlich auch auf die Suche als Paläoökologe nach Referenzen von Gebieten, wo es diese natürlichen Moore noch gibt. Und dann zeigt es sich, dass die lebenden Moore eigentlich sehr viele Parallelen haben mit Organismen.
Die Moore wachsen, die organisieren sich selbst, die regulieren sich selbst und es sind ich sage mal von fast allen Ökosystemen die meist unabhängigen, organismusähnliche Systeme, die es gibt.
Unabhängig von was? Unabhängig von anderen?
Vom Umfeld. Zum Beispiel Wälder ändern sich stark, wenn das Klima sich ändert. Das sehen wir ja in der Geschichte der Wälder dann. Migrieren andere Arten und der Wald ändert sich grundsätzlich in seinem Verhalten und seiner Struktur. Ein Moor als torfbildendes System, viele Moore, nicht alle, es gibt viele Moorentypen, die bauen im Laufe der Zeit, wir nennen das Selbstregulationsmechanismen, auf, womit sie eine negative Rückkopplung kreieren gegenüber Änderungen und stabilisieren sie so. Man kann das vergleichen mit Menschen, die als kleines Kind noch sehr vielem Schutz bedürfen, aber durch ihre Entwicklung doch eine bestimmte Selbstständigkeit kriegen und mal nach draußen gehen können, ohne all zu viel Schutz, wenn es kalt ist und wenn es warm ist, was man als kleines Baby nicht kann. Und das machen die Moore eigentlich auch.
Und das hat mich dann doch auch sehr fasziniert dieses Verhalten von Mooren und damit war auch die Brücke gelegt für mein Interesse in Verhaltensforschung. Und so ist das dann zufällig gekommen. Naja man wird davon getrieben. Der richtige Schub ist dann gekommen, weil ich damals so Ende der 70er Jahre eine NGO gegründet hatte, eine Moorschutzgruppe. Die sich richtig vertiefen musste in die Wissenschaft von Moor, weil ein Torfabbauer kam mit der revolutionären Idee, um ein Moor abzubauen, damit 10 Millionen zu verdienen, aber nach der Abtorfung auf eine Weise einzurichten, dass es aus Naturschutzsicht wertvoller war als vorher.
Das war damals ein revolutionärer Gedanke und jetzt wird noch immer mit diesem Gedanken sehr stark gespielt. Aber ich habe mich dann sehr darin vertieft in die ganze Sache von der Wiederherstellung von Mooren, nachdem die kaputt gemacht worden sind. Aus dem Grund, dass ich diesem Burschen nicht vertraute, ich mochte ihn nicht. Der wichtigste Grund war wohl, dass er sagte, ja ich gehe das dann abgraben, etwas kaputt machen, ich verdiene gutes Geld damit und ich mache etwas schönes daraus und ich gebe das wieder zurück an die Gesellschaft, unter der Bedingung, dass Sie das Moor nach mir benennen. Und das letzte war dann der Tropfen, der den Eimer überlaufen ließ, weil ich dachte, das ist lächerlich. Das ist lächerlich, das ist so eine Arroganz und da gehe ich quer dagegen.
Und es war nicht so viel bekannt wissenschaftlich über Moore und da habe ich mein erstes Buch über Moore gekauft, Moor- und Torfkunde. Das war ein Buch, was gerade in Deutschland erschienen war, wo einiges drin stand. Und dann habe ich mich darin vertieft und dann hat es mich richtig gegriffen so, ab 78 und da habe ich gesagt, Moore das ist wohl mein Ding. Und seitdem beschäftige ich mich mit Mooren überall in der Welt und in fast allen Aspekten, die ich überblicken kann. So ich nenne mich Moorkunde und Paläoökologie, nicht nur Ökologie, weil Ökologie wäre zu beschränkt, obwohl Ökologie natürlich schon eine sehr umfassende Wissenschaft ist, aber ich finde es auch interessant zu sehen, wie Menschen mit Mooren umgehen, wie Menschen Moore kaputt gemacht, wie Menschen Moore ausnutzen und auch wie Menschen Moore wiederherstellen, wie Menschen von Mooren profitieren, Ökosystemdienstleistungen.
Aber auch wie Moore Kultur inspiriert haben. Auf welche Weise Moore Politik beeinflusst haben. Zum Beispiel, dass Moore eigentlich ganz wichtig gewesen sind in der russischen Revolution, das wissen die wenigsten. Das Lenin während der russischen Revolution ein Buch über Moore gelesen hat, das wissen die wenigstens. Dass es eigentlich viele Beziehungen gibt zwischen Mooren und menschlicher Geschichte. Und das sind auch Elemente, die mich faszinieren.
Das ist ja nun gerade in den Niederlanden sehr offensichtlich. Ich meine das Land ist nun dafür bekannt, mit Wasser und Erde am kreativsten umzugehen für eine menschliche Nutzung, insofern liegt es ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht nahe. Ist überhaupt irgendein Land dieser Welt in dem Maße so mit Wasser und Erde verbunden? Gut in Asien wird sich da wahrscheinlich auch viel finden.
Ja, aber ich sage mal die intense Beziehung mit Menschen gibt es sonst nirgendwo. Mal einige Sachen nennen. Die Niederlande bestand zu mehr als der Hälfte aus Moor. Die haben sehr früh angefangen, die Moore zu entwässern, um sie zu nutzen. Das hat schon in der Römerzeit angefangen. Aber vor allem so seit halbwegs Mittelalter, und das ist sehr systematisch gegangen. Sie haben großflächig Moore entwässert und dann kommt etwas gucken, was in den Niederlanden schon schnell sich zeigte, dass wenn man Moore entwässert … ich muss sagen, diese Torfablagerungen die geschieht durch Wassersättigung. Diese Substanzen, diese Pflanzensubstanzen rotten nicht vollständig weg, weil sie gesättigt sind mit Wasser.
Man kann das vergleichen mit Spreewaldgurken, eigentlich das gleiche Prinzip. Wenn man etwas unter Wasser hält, so dass kein Sauerstoff dazu kann und man macht es auch noch etwas sauer, dann kann man sehr lange organisches Material aufbewahren. Mit Hering funktioniert das auch.
Und die Moorleichen haben sich ja auch immer …
Die Moorleichen haben sich auch bewährt in dieser Hinsicht. Das funktioniert. In dem Moment, wo man die Fläche dann nutzt für eine entwässerungsbasierte Landwirtschaft und die Moore entwässert, indem man Gräben gräbt, sackt der Wasserstand und dringt wieder Sauerstoff in den Torfkörper hinein und das führt dann dazu, dass der Torf abgebaut wird sehr schnell. Das hat große Folgen für das Klima, das ist ein anderes Thema, vielleicht reden wir später darüber, aber was ich für die Geschichte der Niederlande sagen möchte, es führt auch zu einem Höhenverlust. Entwässerte Moore hier in unseren temperaten Bereichen verlieren jedes Jahr 1-2 Zentimeter Höhe. In den Niederlanden hat das dazu geführt, dass ein Land, was früher über dem Meeresspiegel lag, jetzt mit der Hälfte unter dem Meeresspiegel liegt.
Wenn man weiß, dass man vor tausend Jahren in der Niederlanden an einigen Stellen angefangen hat, die Moore zu entwässern und man weiß, dass man einen Zentimeter Höhe pro Jahr verliert, dann versteht man, wie es in den Niederlanden möglich gewesen ist, dass Bereiche der Niederlande jetzt 8.5 Meter tiefer liegen als vor tausend Jahren. Die Niederlande hat sich selbst …
… in die Erde gegraben.
… runtergewirtschaftet. Buchstäblich. Die haben damit, ich sage mal, sehr viel Geld gemacht, weil das war die erste Nation, die fast unbeschränkte Verfügbarkeit über Energie hatte. Und damit hat sie das goldene Jahrhundert ja finanzieren können.
Also Energie in Form von Torf?
In Form von Torf. Womit man die ganze ökonomische Kraft entwickelt hat, um als kleines Land eine Weltmacht zu werden und große Teile der Welt in Südostasien und in Südamerika zu erobern und das wieder als Quelle für Wohlfahrt zu verwenden. Aber das war auf Torf gebaut. Und andere Sachen, die wir mit den Niederlanden assoziieren, sind direkt mit Torf verknüpft, zum Beispiel Mühlen. Windmühlen sind Wasserpumpen. In dem Moment, wo das Moor so tief gesackt ist, dass es eigentlich vom Meer überflutet werden würde, muss man das Meer draußen halten, muss man Deiche bauen. Und dann geht man einen Wasserstand führen, der tiefer liegt als der Meeresspiegel, dafür muss man pumpen.
Die Fläche, die ein Wasserstand hat unabhängig von Vorfluter oder vom Meer heißen Polder. Und die Polder sind eine niederländische Erfindung und die werden trockengepumpt, die windbetrieben waren. Die Windmühle, die Polder, die Deiche, alles was wir so mit den Niederlanden assoziieren, ist direkt mit Torf verknüpft. Und deshalb ist die Niederlande tatsächlich ein Torfland. Die niederländische Kultur ist derartig von Torf geprägt, dass das selbst in der Politik heutzutage seine Auswirkungen hat. Wir haben in der Politik das Konzept des Polderns, das bedeutet, dass man sich zusammensetzt und so lange redet, bis man eine Lösung gefunden hat.
Im Vergleich mit Deutschland und mein Umzug nach Deutschland war eine kulturelle Erdverschiebung für unsere Familie, die Niederlande ist vollständig flach organisiert, wo Deutschland viel hierarchisch organisiert ist. In einem Land, wo man Polder hat, und jedes Individuum verantwortlich ist für die Pflege von einem Stück des Deiches, gibt es keine Hierarchie.
Weil alle dafür zuständig ist, dass alles nicht überschwemmt.
Alle können alle anderen umbringen. Und das bedeutet, dass man einen anderen Umgang miteinander realisiert. Ich denke, dass das einer der Gründe ist, dass die Niederlande anders organisiert ist, auch politisch.
Ja interessant.
Und so sieht man, dass Landschaften ihren Einfluss haben auf menschliche Kultur. Und diese Dialektik sozusagen finde ich sehr faszinierend.
Dann kommen wir doch nochmal auf die Moore als solche. Also das normale Verständnis ist, naja da gibt es halt so einen Ort, der ist ein bisschen nass und wenn man nicht aufpasst, dann rutscht man rein und wird zur Moorleiche. Viele Moore sieht man jetzt nicht unbedingt, wenn man sich nicht bemüht, welche zu finden, aber komplett verloren ist es ja glaube auch alles noch nicht. Sie haben ja jetzt schon ein bisschen angedeutet, was Moore sind, aber ich würde es nochmal bisschen genauer verstehen. Also wie kam es überhaupt dazu, dass sich diese Flächen ausgebildet haben, wo mehr Wasser sich sammelt? Dass diese Moore überhaupt entstehen konnten. Was war der Auslöser dafür?
Ja grundsätzlich muss man eine dauerhafte Anwesenheit von Wasser haben. Man muss ausreichend Wasserzufuhr haben. Das Wasser darf nicht zu viel sein, weil dann nennt man das einen See. Und Seen können sich auch zu Mooren entwickeln, wenn sie verlanden, wie wir das nennen. Ein See lagert auch Material ab. Dieses Plankton in einem Meer und die Wasserpflanzen, die sterben auch ab und das fällt auch nach unten auf den Boden. Das ist dieser Schlamm, den man fühlt, wenn man Baden geht und so weiter zwischen den Zehen und so und das lagert sich auch ab. So ein See veruntieft sich im Laufe der Jahre und kann dann auch so untief werden, dass Sumpfpflanzen wachsen können. Und diesen Prozess nennen wir Verladung. Das ist dann eine Situation, wie ein Moor entstehen kann.
Aber ein Moor kann auch entstehen, wenn man kein tiefes Wasser hat, aber wohl höhere Wasserstände über Flur, die ziemlich stabil sind. Denn man kann grundsätzlich sagen, dass Torf, wenn es entwässert ist, zwanzigfach schneller abbaut, als dass es sich produziert, wenn es nass ist. Die Produktion von diesem organischen Material und die Ablagerung geschieht nur, wenn der Boden 95% der Zeit wassergesättigt ist. Solche Gebiete gibt es, auch von der Natur. Zum Beispiel wo ausreichend Wasser zufließt aus einem Einzugsgebiet oder am Rand von Meeren oder Seen oder am Rand von Flüssen oder aber wo der Niederschlag ausreichend ist.
Wir haben auch sehr nasse Gebiete in der Welt, wo Moorbildung stattfindet auf diesem Tisch, wenn man ihn ausreichend lange draußen stehen hat. Aber in den meisten Fällen ist eine Kombination von Niederschlag, der immer wichtig ist, und Zulauf von Wasser aus der Umgebung, was letztendlich auch Niederschlag ist, was früher mal gefallen ist und ausgeglichen durch Abstand in diese Depression gelangt, wo dann das Moor zur Entwicklung kommt.
Das heißt das Moor entsteht in dem Moment, wo es eine bestimmte Balance gibt aus Wasserzuführung, aber nicht so viel, dass es sich einfach nur staut und man eben einen See erhält, aber es eben auch nie abreißt, sondern kontinuierlich im Prinzip so einen gut wachsenden Pflanzenvorrat einfach bewässert, aber diesen auch immer mehr oder weniger einschließt. Also das heißt im Wasser entwickeln sich diese Prozesse und alles was dort wächst stirbt dann auch irgendwann, aber es stirbt nicht so wie es an der frischen Luft sterben würde, indem es dann einfach komplett vertrocknet wegfliegt und sich um andere Bereiche kümmert, sondern es verbleibt vor Ort und sickert ein und dann greifen andere Prozesse. Was passiert dann?
Dann kriegt man wie die Moore selbst mit der Landschaft interferieren gehen. Wenn man zum Beispiel bei uns in Nordostdeutschland, hier auch, hat man diese Gletschertäler, wo die abschmelzenden Gletscher ihr Wasser abströmen lassen haben Richtung Ostsee. Das sind tiefe Täler, die haben sich allmählich mit Torf gefüllt, weil die Grundwasserzufuhr gehabt haben aus einem weiten Einzugsgebiet, die Moränenplatten. Diese Torfbildung hat dann eigentlich den freien Ablauf des Wassers immer mehr blockiert. Wo erst ein Flusstal war, hat sich nachher allmählich ein immer dickeres Moor gebildet und hat damit die Abwasserung frustriert. Und das hat dann zur Folge gehabt, dass auch der Wasserstand im Einzugsgebiet gestiegen ist, weil das Wasser konnte nicht mehr wegfließen.
Und das hat auch dazu geführt, dass dann Täler Depressionen höher gelegen, die früher trocken waren, durch die Bildung von Mooren tiefer, nasser geworden sind und neue Moore sich dort gebildet haben.
Also ein natürlicher Stausee quasi?
So etwas ja. Und dann hat man auch noch die Moore, wenn die dann gewachsen sind und Vorrat an Wasser entwickeln und Selbstregulationsmechanismen entwickeln, dass sie das Wasser halten können, dass sie dann in der Lage sind, sich auch noch auszubreiten wie ein Schwamm nach draußen wachsen. Wenn die einmal, manche Moore, wenn die einmal angefangen haben, dann wachsen die weiter sozusagen. Und da gibt es auch die Parallele mit den Pflanzen.
Was passiert dann in diesem Moor, das es eben so besonders macht? Also dieser Abbau oder dieser nicht vollständige Abbau von Pflanzen, was entsteht da, was ist dieser Torf, was macht ihn so anders als normale Böden?
Bei normalen Böden hat man auch oft organisches Material, aber das ist viel stärker zersetzt. Man kriegt, wenn man organisches Material abbaut unter Einfluss von Sauerstoff kriegt man eigentlich zwei Prozesse. Eine ist Mineralisierung, das bedeutet, dass die organische Substanz wieder zurückgebaut wird zu mineralischen Substanzen, sprich Wasser und Kohlendioxyd und auch einige andere, aber das sind die wichtigsten. Woraus die Pflanzenmasse früher durch Fotosynthese entstanden ist. Aber man kriegt noch einen anderen Prozess und der heißt Humifizierung. Humifizierung ist eigentlich, man hat komplexe organische Moleküle, die zerschneidet man in kleinere Blöcke. Teile davon werden dann vollständig kaputt gemacht, das ist der Mineralisierungsteil, aber Teile davon werden wieder miteinander verknüpft und bauen dann neue Komplexe, die stabiler sind und resistenter sind als das Material aus dem sie hervorgegangen sind.
Man baut das Material um, jedenfalls ein Teil. Es ist eine Art von natürlicher Selektion. Denn man kann einfach sagen, nur das Zeug, was stabiler wird, wird überleben und wenn es schwächer wird ist es schneller weg. Das ist eine Art von Selektion.
Aber das ist dann der Humus? Das ist dann die neue Erde?
Das ist der Humus. In normalen Böden findet man diesen Humus dann zurück als amorphes schwarzes Zeug. In Mooren findet man auch dieses amorphe schwarze Zeug, aber auch noch Pflanzenreste, die überhaupt nicht kaputt gemacht sind. Das sind nicht vollständige Pflanzenreste, aber das sind die Teile von Pflanzen, die am stabilsten sind. Wände, Holzgefäße und solche Sachen. Das hat damit zu tun, dass der Aufbau dieser organischen Moleküle, manche organischen Moleküle sind sehr schnell weg. Zucker, das wird sofort verzehrt, aber Holz, es gibt nicht so schrecklich viele Organismen, die Holz fressen können. Kühen kann man kein Holz füttern, Ziege wohl, aber … Da findet dann eine Selektion statt, dass die Teile der Pflanze, die am meisten zersetzungsresistent sind, eigentlich übrig bleiben.
Und dann dauert es eigentlich eine Weile, bis dieses Material in die Lage, eine Schicht gekommen ist, die dauernd wassergesättigt ist und dann findet die Zersetzung kaum noch statt. Die Phase, wo noch Sauerstoff zutreten kann, so die oberste Schicht des Moores, wo Wasserstandsschwankungen stattfinden. Wasserstandsschwankungen hat man fast immer. Man hat niemals ein sehr gleichmäßiges Wasser.
Da verdunstet mal was.
Es verdunstet sehr viel. Das meiste Wasser das regnet verdunstet, das vergessen die meisten Leute auch. Es ist eine Phase, ein Bereich, wo das organische Material, die Pflanzenreste abgebaut werden. Die schwächeren weiter, die starken weniger weit bis dahin, dass sie dann in die Schicht kommen, die wassergesättigt ist und da wird das dann konserviert und da hat man dann – und das ist abhängig von was für Pflanzen gewachsen sind und ist abhängig, wie schnell der Wassersättigungseffekt, dieser Absaufungseffekt stattfindet, wie stark zersetzt diese Torfe dann sind. Wir haben Torfe, die tausende Jahre alt sind, wo man noch jedes Moosblättchen wiederkennen kann. Mann hat auch Torfe, die sind so zersetzt, dass selbst Staubmehl, was sehr resistent ist, auch kaputt korridiert ist. Das sind dann die unterschiedlichen Torftypen, die man dann auch hat.
Also dass so viel von den Pflanzen übrig bleibt und sie eben nicht so wie an der frischen Luft komplett zersetzt und ihre Bestandteile aufgespalten sind, das ist das was diesen hohen Energiegehalt des Torfes ausmacht?
Ja. Unsere fossilen Brennstoffe, wie Steinkohle, Braunkohle und ein Großteil des Öls sind Torfe aus der Vergangenheit.
Die einfach noch mehr komprimiert wurden und noch stärker zersetzt sind?
Diese Kohlenbildung ist ein chemischer Prozess unter Einfluss von hohem Druck und hohen Temperaturen. Man muss ein Moor unter die Erde schießen lassen durch Tektonik. Wir haben diese schwimmenden, treibenden Kontinente und die tauchen dann untereinander und dann geht auch diese Moorablagerung herunter und die kommen dann unter Druck und unter Hitze und dadurch verändern die sich in Steinkohle. Wir können das auch künstlich tun. Es gibt so Fabriken, bei uns in Anklamm haben wir so ein Ding stehen, das macht in einigen Stunden aus Biomasse Kohlen, nur durch hohen Druck und hohe Temperatur. Das ist ein ganz einfacher chemischer Prozess. Wir müssen einfach sehen, dass unsere Steinkohle eigentlich herkömmlich von Riesenmooren aus dem Carbon 300 Millionen Jahre her ist.
Wo die Urwälder damals, Tropenwälder waren das weitestgehend, aber es gab auch temperate Wälder, Torf abgelagert haben, die dann später zu Steinkohle umgewandelt wurden. Und das gleiche gilt auch für Braunkohle hier in der Lausitz und so weiter. Das sieht man auch. Das Material ist das gleiche, da kann man auch die Pflanzenreste rausholen. Ein Großteil von unseren fossilen Brennstoffen sind eigentlich fossile Torfe.
Das heißt ein Moor ist im Prinzip dasselbe wie ein Ölvorkommen, nur sehr viel jünger.
Ja so kann man das sagen. Es hat vergleichbare Mengen an Kohlenstoff. Die Steinkohlenvorräte sind nicht so grundsätzlich viel größer als die Torfvorräte. Es ist nur weniger kompakt und es ist weniger, die Torfe enthalten noch viel mehr Sauerstoff und Wasserstoff in ihren Molekülen. Bei diesem Verkohlungsprozess findet einfach eine Abtrennung statt von Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff und wird das immer purere Kohlenstoff bis hin zu Anthrazit, was 99% Kohlenstoff ist. Torf und Pflanzen haben einen Kohlenstoffgehalt von pi mal Daumen 50%. Zucker hat noch etwas weniger. Pflanzen haben 50%, Torfe, etwas zersetzte Torfe haben 55%. Braunkohle geht zu 60%, schlechte Kohle geht zu 80% und dann geht man 90-99% bis man pures Grafit oder Diamant hat. Dann hat man 100% Kohlenstoff.
Und das ist diese Verkohlungsreihe. Eigentlich das weniger brennbare Zeug wird abgetrennt und man konzentriert somit das brennbare Zeug.
Das heißt die Konzentration im Vergleich zu Holz ist jetzt gar nicht so sehr viel höher, trotzdem ist Torf aber ein viel besserer Brennstoff?
Torf ist nicht so schrecklich viel besser als Holz. Es ist manchmal besser kompaktiert durch diese Zersetzung. Und bei Torf gibt es auch große Unterschiede. Bei uns im Moor haben die im Mittelalter immer versucht, tief ins Moor zu graben. 3-4 Meter unter Wasser zu graben, weil dort die stark zersetzen Torfe saßen, die eigentlich fast ähnlich waren wie Steinkohle. Die nasseren Torfe, die unter nasseren Bedingungen gebildet sind, es ist nicht unbedingt verknüpft mit dem Alter, die so locker wie Stroh und brennen auch entsprechend, tüchtig, aber schnell, nicht dauerhaft. Und früher war es natürlich vor allem gewollt, um dauerhaft brennende Brennstoffe zu haben, das nicht jede Minute Nachschub brauchte.
Also um Öfen zu betreiben, Heizungen etc.?
Ja.
Das erklärt, warum jetzt zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt die Menschheit dazu übergegangen ist, diese Moore quasi auszurauben und ihrer alten Einlagerungen zu berauben. Und das im wesentlichen als Energiespeicher zu verwenden. Und das bedeutet dann eben genauso wie auch bei der Kohle, genauso wie beim Erdöl, dass darin gebundenes CO2 durch das Verbrennen auch wieder freigesetzt wird?
Ja, also Torfe sind zwar jünger, aber sie sind genauso fossil wie Kohle. Oft wird gesagt auch von der Torfindustrie, dass Torf näher verwandt ist mit Pflanzenmaterial als mit Kohle. Das gilt natürlich, wenn man sagt, ja wenn man Alter anguckt oder Zersetzungsgrad, aber alle Steinkohle kommt auch von Pflanzen, das ist auch mal gewachsen. Und Steinkohle entstand auch noch jeden Tag neu, weil diese Kohlifizierungsprozesse und die tektonischen Prozesse haben sich in den letzten Milliarden Jahren nicht geändert. Auch Steinkohle entsteht jeden Tag neu, nur verdammt wenig und wir verbrenn viel mehr. Und das ist mit Moor und Torf eigentlich genau das gleiche.
Man sieht eigentlich in der Geschichte, man hat damit angefangen, Holz zu verbringen. Und die Torfgewinnung ist eigentlich erst großflächig interessant geworden, sicher hier in Deutschland, nachdem die Wälder abgeholzt waren und dann hat man gesehen, wir können auch Moore nutzen zur Verbrennung, aber auch dort hat man sofort die Endlichkeit der Ressource betrachtet. Ich gebe einen Kurs über Moorrestauration und in einem halben Tag von diesem Kurs gebe ich den Studenten allen alte Literatur von vor 1850, weil es wurde vor 1850 unglaublich viel geschriben über die Wiedererzeugung von Torfen, die Restauration von Torfen. Im ersten wissenschaftlichen Buch über Torf überhaupt, Tractatus de Turffis von Martinus Schoock aus Groningen 1658 glaube ich.
Da steht schon ein Kapitel drin, ob man diesen Torf, nachdem man ihn abgegraben hat, auch wieder nachwachsen lassen kann, restaurieren kann. So die Frage der Nachhaltigkeit hat da schon eine Rolle gespielt. Man hat gesehen, die Wälder sind endlich, dann hat man mit den Mooren angefangen. Dann hat man am Anfang gesehen, Mensch die wachsen noch schlimmer nach. Man hat gedacht, wie können wir die wieder nachwachsen lassen. Es gibt riesige Bände Literatur über Moorrestauration von vor 1850. Diese ist vollständig verschwunden nach 1850, so um diese Zeit, weil dann Steinkohle …
… Auf einmal viel wichtiger war.
… Erfunden wurde, was noch bequemer war, was noch kompakter war und auch was unbeschränkt vorhanden. So diese Parallelen sind ganz klar. Ein Torf ist jünger, aber ist auch fossil. Es würde, wenn es nicht abgebaut würde, genauso wie Steinkohle über Billionen von Jahren aufbewahrt bleiben. Ein Wald ist deshalb nachwachsende, weil wenn man das Holz nicht verbrennen würde, würde es sowieso wieder zu CO2 werden. Vielleicht in 100 Jahren oder 300 Jahren, aber jeder Baum, der jetzt lebt, wird wenn es kein Moor ist, wird wieder zu CO2. Was wir eigentlich tun, wenn wir Biomasse verbrennen, ist, wir klauen eigentlich die Brennstoffe von Mikroben und Pilzen, die sonst das Holz abgebaut hätten für ihre eigenen Zwecke und verwenden das für unsere Zwecke.
Wir ändern nicht die Richtung, wir ändern nur den Pfad. Wobei wir mehr Torfe und Steinkohle verbrennen, dann mobilisieren wir etwas, was sonst nie mobilisiert werden würde. So ist es ein Richtungsunterschied, das hat nichts mit dem Alter oder Geschwindigkeit zu tun, sondern mit der Richtung, wo es hingeht. Biomasse würde wieder in der Luft enden und wir nutzen einfach dieses Zeug durch diesen Weg, wodurch es in die Luft geht, zu ändern und bei fossilen Brennstoffen mobilisieren wir etwas, was es sonst niemals in der Luft gegeben hätte oder kaum.
Also es ist vollkommen offensichtlich, dass auch Moore eine Rolle spielen in diesem ganzen Zyklus und in dem Einfluss auf das Klima. Die Frage ist, wie groß ist dieser Einfluss? Man weiß, dass die Verbrennung von Erdöl, die Verbrennung von Kohle ist ein großes Problem. Wie groß ist das Problem der Ausnutzung von Mooren und dem Trockenlegen von Mooren? Welche Rolle spielen Moore im Gesamtkonzert der Ökologie?
Ja das ist eigentlich disproportional groß. So viele Moore gibt es eigentlich nicht auf der Welt. Wir haben auf der Welt ca. 3% der Landfläche bedeckt mit Mooren. Diese 3% der Moore speichern aber doppelt so viel Kohlenstoff wie alle Biomasse von allen Wäldern der Welt. Und die Wälder bedecken 30% der Erde. So das gibt schon an, wie dicht diese Kohlenstoffdichte ist. Nur ein Kleinteil der Moore der Erde ist entwässert. Wir schätzen 15%. Das beutetet, dass 0,4% der Landfläche der Erde aus entwässerten Mooren besteht. Nur ein sehr kleiner Teil.
Aber diese 0,4% der Landfläche ist heutzutage verantwortlich für 5% aller anthropogenen Treibhausgasemissionen. Einschließlich alles von Verkehr, Klima und so weiter. Das gleiche gilt auch für Deutschland. In manchen anderen Ländern oder Bundesländern ist es anders. In Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sind die entwässerten Moore verantwortlich für über 30% von allen Treibhausgasemissionen. Es ist selbst so, dass die Verluste von CO2 aus den Mooren doppelt so viel sind, als alles was Mecklenburg-Vorpommern einspart mit Windenergie. So Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist ein richtiges Windenergieland und die haben jetzt auch im Meer große Windparks, die sich auch noch ausbreiten. Aber selbst wenn man die Ausbreitung mitrechnet ist alles was man an Windenergie macht, um Emissionen zu verringern und auszusparen und zu vermeiden ist weniger als was die Moore in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern emittieren.
Um das nochmal richtig zu fassen, damit ich das richtig verstehe. Entwässerte Moore, denen man das Wasser genommen hat, um den Torf zu stechen und Land zu gewinnen, warum auch immer, die quasi nur so vor sich hin liegen und der Luft ausgesetzt sind, die die gesamten biochemischen Prozesse einleiten, die sich nicht eingeleitet hätten, wären sie noch mit Wasser bedeckt, geben in diesem Rahmen so viel CO2 ab, wie die Vergleiche, die Sie gerade gebracht haben?
Ja. Ich werde nochmal einige Beispiele geben.
Das ist ja irre.
Die meisten Moore, die wir in Deutschland haben, werden als Grünland verwendet für Vieh. Ein Hektar entwässertes Grünland auf Moor emittiert genauso viel pro Hektar pro Jahr als dass man 135000 km fährt mit einem Mittelklasseauto. Jedes Jahr jeder Hektar. Die Landwirtschaft auf Moor in Deutschland hat eine Emission, die fast doppelt so groß ist wie das Kraftwerk Jänschwalde, hier in Brandenburg. Was das siebt-dreckigste Kraftwerk der Welt ist. Die Landwirtschaft auf Moor ist fast doppelt so dreckig was CO2 angeht als das siebt-dreckigste Kraftwerk der Welt, was auch in Deutschland ist.
Also in Deutschland die Landwirtschaft auf Moorfläche, auf ehemaliger Moorfläche.
Ja nur in Deutschland.
Wie viel ist das hier in Deutschland? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen, was für eine Fläche an Mooren wird für Landwirtschaft genutzt?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß, dass es 6% der landwirtschaftlichen Fläche ist auf Moor. Das ist ein eigentlich nur ein kleiner Teil, aber der ist verantwortlich für immense Emissionen. Disproportional viel. Es ist weltweit so, wenn man die Landwirtschaft nur anguckt, es gibt drei Typen Gase, kommen aus der Landwirtschaft. Das ist Lachgas, ein sehr starkes Treibhausgas.
Methan?
Das ist verantwortlich für etwa 30% von allen Emissionen aus der Landwirtschaft. Und dieses Lachgas kommt nur aus der Dünnung, Kunstdünger weitestgehend. Dann hat man Methane natürlich, das ist auch etwa weltweit verantwortlich für 30% der Treibhausgaseffekte, ausgedrückt in CO2-Equivalenten.
Das kommt aus den Kühen?
Das kommt aus den Kühen und aus den Reisfeldern der Welt. Und ein Drittel ist CO2, das kommt alles aus diesen Mooren, nur aus Mooren.
Das heißt Landwirtschaft ohne Moorflächen hätte gar keine CO2-Emission in dem Sinne?
Ja kann man sagen. All diese CO2-Emissionen und das sind riesige Bänder, die kommen aus dem Moor. In Deutschland ist das betrüblich. Ich glaube, dass aus der Landwirtschaft im Moor etwa 160 Megatonnen CO2 kommen. Sagen nichts diese Zahlen, aber das sind riesige Mengen. Wenn man bedenkt, dass wir – wir hatten gerade über Windmühlen und Solar, das wird subventioniert durch die Regierung, um unsere Emissionen zurückzudrängen. Wenn man die gleichen Subventionskosten, die Schädenvermeidungskosten, wie das dann ökonomisch heißt, ansetzt, um auszurechnen, welchen Schaden Landwirtschaft auf Moor zubringt an unser Klima, was von anderen Teilen der Gesellschaft abgedeckt werden muss, dann ist das interessant, dass pro Hektar – Grünland oder Acker – muss man dann in Größenordnungen denken, dass jeder Hektar Landwirtschaft auf Moor Klimaschäden verursacht in Größenordnungen von 3000 Euro pro Hektar pro Jahr.
Deutschlandweit reden wir über einen Schaden von ich glaube 3,6 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr.
Also volkswirtschaftlicher Schaden?
Volkswirtschaftlicher Schaden, die die Landwirtschaft auf Moor verursacht. Und das interessante ist, ich war vorgestern in Brüssel, um das mal den Leuten dort klarzumachen, das wird subventioniert. Das wird subventioniert ich glaube mit 600 Millionen oder 300 Millionen Euro im Rahmen von was man dann nennt Cross Compliance für die Landwirtschaft. Die Landwirte kriegen Subventionen, um Landwirtschaft zu machen. Wir als Gesellschaft haben von all diesem Grünland einen Schaden von mehr als 3000 Euro pro Hektar pro Jahr. Volkswirtschaftlich ist das vollständiger Blödsinn. Und das wird fett gemacht. Andres Beispiel, wir haben das Energieeinsparungsgesetzt, seitdem man Biogas produzieren kann, und dafür einen garantieren Preis kriegen, haben die Biogasgeneratoren stark zugenommen.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass Moore tiefer entwässert worden sind, um Grünland umzusetzen in Maisacker, weil Mais ist ein sehr gutes Substrat, um Gas zu kreieren. Wenn diese Mais und das wird zunehmend gemacht, jetzt nimmt das nicht mehr zu, aber in den letzten Jahren ist das ziemlich ausgebreitet, wenn das verwendet wird, um Biogas zu machen und man verrechnet den Foodprint davon, dann zeigt sich, dass das Biogas, was wir bezahlen als Biogas, dass das acht mal größere Emissionen hat pro Energieeinheit produziert, als wenn man Braunkohle verheizen würde. Also wir sehen, dass eine ganze Bande, was dann international als "Perverse Incentives" wirken, die eigentlich was wir beabsichtigen …
Genau das Gegenteil befördern.
Genau das Gegenteil bewirken. Und darüber haben wir vorgestern auch bei der EU geredet, dass das doch aufhören muss. Das kann doch nicht so sein, dass die EU einerseits sagt, wir wollen so viel reduzieren und andererseits Geld gibt, dass das Problem instand bleibt und größer wird. So das sind diese Schiefwachstume, die es gibt, sagt man bezüglich der Moore.
Ist das Problem mit diesem Mais und des daraus entstehenden Biogases nur wegen der Moore so, das heißt wenn man Mais woanders anbauen würde, dann wäre das Problem nicht so groß?
Ja dann wäre das Problem viel geringer. Weil dieser Mais braucht Entwässerung. Mais ist eine semiaride Pflanze, das kommt von semitrockenen Bedingungen. Und braucht deshalb Entwässerung. Es ist einfach so, dass für jede 10 Zentimeter, die du tiefer entwässert, kommt 5 Tonnen CO2 pro Hektar mehr raus. Also diese Beziehung zwischen Emissionen aus Mooren und Wasserstand ist fast vollständig linear. Um so tiefer man entwässert, umso mehr Dinge kommen raus. Wenn man ein feuchtes Grasland hat und man sagt, okay wir haben einen Biogasgenerator in der Nähe, da kann ich gut Biomasse verkaufen, am besten Mais, ich einwässere mein Grasland 40 Zentimeter tiefer, kann ich Biogase produzieren. Die Verluste von Kohlenstoff aus dem Boden werden nicht gezählt.
Obwohl Cross Compliants in der EU vorschreibt, dass der Kohlenstoffgehalt im Boden nicht zurückgehen darf, haben die nur Regeln entworfen für Mineralböden, wo es eigentlich nicht relevant ist und für die Moore gelten diese Regeln nicht. Das wird einfach außerhalb der Berechnung gehalten. Das ist das gleiche Problem Mais auf Moor, wie das große Ölpumpproblem auf Moor in Asien. Das ist auch weitgehend stimuliert durch Kyoto-Protokoll, Anfrage, Nachfrage von Niederlande und Deutschland. Niederlande hat drei Milliarden Euro gegeben, um Palmöl anzubauen, dass die mehr Bioöl kriegen konnten, um ihre Kyoto-Verpflichtungen zu tun. Und das würde hier dann als eine Reduktion gezählt, obwohl es zu fünf mal größeren Emissionen geführt hat durch Entwässerungen von Mooren in Südostasien. Das sind die Schlupflöcher im Klimasystem.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, Moore sind erst mal viel wichtiger für das Gesamtökosystem, als man sich das vielleicht normalerweise klarmacht. Einfach weil sie extreme CO2-Speicher sind und in dem Moment, wo man ihnen das Wasser entzieht, hören sie nicht auf, das auch freizulegen. In dem Moment, wo man Moore für Landwirtschaft nutzt oder nur für Landgewinnung als solche und sie einfach trocken herumstehen lässt und ihnen kein Wasser zuführt, ist es im Prinzip so ein Fass ohne Boden, wie so eine Ölfontäne, die irgendwie von so einem angebohrten Ölfeld irgendwie herausschießt.
Das heißt eigentlich müsste man wieder Wasser draufmachen? Würde das helfen?
Ja.
Ja, wir sitzen mit der fremden Situation, die ist historische gewachsen, dass unsere Landwirtschaft im Mittelosten entstanden ist. Die ist unter trockenen Bedingungen entstanden. Ich sage immer Halbwüste. Es war keine Halbwüste, aber es war sehr trocken. Und unsere wichtigsten landwirtschaftlichen Pflanzen kommen auch aus dieser Gegend. Und wir haben diese Kenntnis, diese Illusion, dass Land trocken sein muss und dauernd gepflügt werden muss, einfach überall angewandt. Wir haben die Landwirtschaft nicht angepasst an die Gegebenheiten der Landschaft, aber wir haben die Landschaft angepasst an die ziemlich begrenzten Anforderungen einer Landwirtschaft, die in der Wüste entstanden ist, um es mal so zu sagen. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass wir auf großem Maßstab für die Landwirtschaft, auch für die Forstwirtschaft Moore entwässert haben.
Und das verursacht das Problem. Um diese Probleme von Moorsackung, die langfristig zur Flutung von großem flachem Land führen werden und von Emissionen zu verringern und zu beschränken und anzuhalten, muss man die Mooren wieder vernassen. Der Punkt ist, dass die meisten Moore keine Wildnismoore sind, sind nicht in Schutzgebieten. Die meisten Moore, über die wir reden, wenn wir über Moor oder Klima reden, reden wir nicht über Moore in Schutzgebieten, sondern wir reden über was normale Leute Weiden oder Wiesen nennen oder Acker oder Wälder. Wir reden über Kühe auf Moor, wir reden über Mais auf Moor, wir reden über Wälder auf Moor und die werden nicht mehr als Moore gesehen, obwohl sie wohl Moore sind. Wenn man die Moore sieht als Ablagerungen von organischen Substanzen.
Es wird verdrängt, viele Leute denken, einschließlich in der Klimakonvention, dass wenn man über Moore redet, dass man über die kleineren Reste redet, die noch irgendwo übrig geblieben sind, die vielleicht geschützt werden oder vielleicht nicht, nein wir reden über Mainstream landwirtschaftliche und forstwirtschaftliche Nutzung. Die die Moore so angepasst haben an ein auf Trockenheit basiertes Ideal, dass diese Probleme entstanden sind. Und die einzige Lösung ist, wenn wir diese Fläche nicht vollständig aufgeben wollen und das können wir letztendlich nicht, weil die Frage nach Land und Biomasse nimmt noch immer zu aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen, müssen wir eine Methode finde, dass wir diese Moore wieder vernässen können und damit diese negativen Aspekte blockieren können, ohne dass wir die Produktion und die Nutzung anhalten.
Also müssen wir umdenken in Land- und Forstwirtschaft. Wir müssen Land- und Forstwirtschaft entwickeln, dass sie auf nassen Systemen basiert. Es ist überhaupt kein Problem, Schilf produziert genauso viel Biomasse wie Mais. Schilf kann man auch nutzen für Biogas. Es ist eine Änderung von Gewächsen, aber wir sitzen mit den historisch während 10000 Jahren gewachsenen Kulturen, einer Landeskultur, die basiert ist auf eine Ideologie aus der Wüste.
Das heißt man muss eigentlich hingehen und schauen, wie kann man dasselbe Ziel erreichen mit anderen Methoden. Wie kann man quasi die Nutzpflanzen auch generieren, die man haben möchte, ohne gleich alles trocken zu legen?
Ja. Oder was wir hier tun müssen ist, alles wieder nass machen. Und die Landwirtschaft anpassen, dass man statt Trockenheit fordernde Pflanzen feuchte Nasspflanzen anbaut. Und dieses System, diese Art von Landwirtschaft nennen wir Paludikultur. Wir haben uns mal ein Wort ausdenken müssen, weil wenn man sagt Sumpfwirtschaft, das trägt sich nicht so gut, das hat eine etwas negative Konnotation und deshalb ist das Wort Paludikultur kreiert, wie man Agrikultur hat und Silvikultur und Aquakultur und so weiter. Was eigentlich das gleiche bedeutet, das ist die Kultivierung von Sümpfen vom Palus, das lateinische Wort Palus. Und das versuchen wir schon seit einigen Jahren, 15 Jahre maßgeblich in Greifswald zu entwicklen.
Da haben wir große Forschungsprojekte laufen und das läuft eigentlich gut. Das sieht auch sehr vielversprechend aus. Es wird weit übernommen. Viele Länder orientieren sich daran als Lösung. Zum Beispiel in zwei Wochen wir ein großer Workshop stattfinden in Indonesien über Paludikultur, weil dort hat man solche riesigen Probleme mit entwässerten Mooren, da haben die letzten Jahre zwei Millionen Hektar Moore gebrannt. Da kommt dieses Jahr ich denke 10% vielleicht 20% von allen Emissionen der Welt kommen nur von den brennenden Mooren in Indonesien. Und die Indonesier, sie machen sich nicht so schrecklich viel Sorgen über den Klimaeffekt. Aber diesen Rauch, diesen "Haze", den man hat, ist eine richtige Katastrophe. Da gehen hunderte Leute ins Krankenhaus, weil die nicht atmen können.
10% der Kinder haben Lungenkrankheiten, weil die ein halbes Jahr jedes Jahr in Rauch leben müssen. Singapur und Kualalumpur werden ökonomisch einfach blockiert, weil kein Flugverkehr und kein Handel stattfinden kann, weil dieser Rauch dort ist und deshalb hat der Präsident einfach gesagt, wir müssen in den nächsten fünf Jahren zwei Millionen Hektar Moor wieder vernässen. Das ist eine Illusion. Der weiß nicht genau worüber er redet. Aber dass die jetzt zu der Überzeugung gekommen sind, dass es nicht anders geht und die haben dann eine Kommission direkt unter dem Präsident organisiert. Die haben jetzt ein Moorrestaurationsprogramm direkt unter dem Präsidenten. Ich war vor einigen Wochen, vor 2-3 Monaten auch da und das war auch ein Workshop. Und das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass man fünf Minister hat, die mitdenken, die mitreden.
So seriös wird das Problem genommen. Und jetzt hat man erkannt, wir können diese zwei Millionen Hektar, die sind für einen bestimmten Zwecke entwässert, genauso wie hier. Die Leute haben das nicht zum Spaß gemacht. Die haben das für Produktion für Landwirtschaft und Forstwirtschaft gemacht. Und wir sehen, dass es immer mehr Bedarf gibt an Produkten von Land, einerseits weil die Zahl der Menschen auf der Erde noch immer zunimmt und zunehmen wird bis 2050. Was in Indonesien natürlich eine Rolle spielt. Das ist ein Land mit 240 Millionen Einwohner. Und ein Großteil dieser Leute ist sauarm. Denen muss man aus Gerechtigkeitsgründen auch noch was mehr gönnen. Wir können nicht sagen, Leute wir haben ein schlechtes Klima, bleibt ihr bitte arm. Das kann man nicht machen. Das lässt sich nicht verkaufen. Und als drittes haben wir jetzt beschlossen, dass wir unsere ganze Ökonomie dekarbonisieren müssen, das ist in Paris beschlossen.
Das bedeutet eigentlich, dass alle fossile Kohlenstoffe - und das ist Wasser, wenn wir hier uns umgucken und denken, was alles aus Öl gemacht worden ist, alle Plastik und so weiter, kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Das muss alles ersetzt werden durch Kohlenstoffe, die von Pflanzen produziert werden. Wir müssen das Land, sicher das Land was degradiert ist, was schon der Wildnis entnommen ist, müssen wir produktiv halten. Und für Moore bedeutet das einfach Paludikultur. Wir müssen dort Sachen anbauen. Und das geht auch. Wir haben auch dort Forschung gemacht und so weiter und es ist schon eine Liste von tausend Pflanzenarten, die im Sumpfwald wachsen, die man nützlich verwenden kann. Wenn man statt Palmöl Sago anbaut. Für Sago braucht man kein Moor zu entwässern. Es gibt andere Arten hochproduktiver Nüsse im Sumpfwald, die man kommerziell anbauen kann. Und das ist die Herausforderung sicher für Indonesien, aber ähnliche Herausforderungen haben wir hier.
Ja fast alles.
Dass wir sicher für diese Moorfläche andersartige Gewächse, andersartige Produktionsstrukturen entwickeln gehen.
Klingt jetzt schon so ein bisschen, als ob sich so langsam da der Gedanke durchsetzt, dass das wirklich ein Problem ist. So richtig neu ist diese … Also ich weiß nicht, wie jung ist diese Erkenntnis aus der Forschung? Also wie lange ist das klar, dass der Beitrag von trockenen Mooren zum CO2-Ausstoß so hoch ist? Weiß man das schon lange?
Nein das weiß man nicht lange. Weil man das eigentlich kaum berücksichtigt hat. Weil natürlich auch die Forschungsdaten nicht vorlagen. Ich bin seit 2006 aktiv in der Klimakommission. Ich sage mal, diese Erkenntnisse sind jünger als zehn Jahre. Die Zahlen, die es so gibt, von wie viele Moore emittieren, zum Beispiel was ich gerade Zahl gesagt habe von Grönland, die sind erst in 2014 von dem Weltklimarat entwickelt. Da haben wir einige Jahre dran gearbeitet, um alle Kenntnisse zusammenzukriegen. Und das Maß an Forschung ist natürlich auch sehr groß und wir kriegen auch dauernd neue Einsichten. Aber die grundlegende Idee, dass Moore wichtig sein könnten für das Klima, außerhalb von pur propagandistischen Zwecken hat man das natürlich immer gesagt, aber das war nicht richtig begründbar.
Diese Einsichten, diese wissenschaftlichen Einsichten sind erst in den letzten zehn Jahren gekommen, auch dieses Ausmaß.
Dafür klingt das ja schon, als ob es noch eine ganze Menge Wiederhall gibt für diese Ergebnisse? Also wenn ich mir das jetzt so anhöre, was da in Indonesien passiert, okay das mag ausgehen von der Problematik der Verbrennung und der Luftverschmutzung und der entsprechenden Belastung. Aber dass man jetzt trotzdem darauf einschwenkt und sieht, okay wir müssen jetzt auch mal was mit den Mooren machen, ist ja schon mal beruhigend.
Naja, man sieht eigentlich, dass die Moore in den letzten zehn Jahren richtig an …
Bedeutung? Einfluss? Relevanz?
Wie heißt das Wort, dass man Erkenntnis davon hat, dass sie relevant sind. Das haben die sehr stark gewonnen. Ich weiß noch 2006 hat keiner in der Klimakommission jemals richtig über Moore nachgedacht. Man muss sich auch vorstellen, die Moore sind nur 3% der Landfläche der Erde. Die Wälder sind 30%. Dass die Moore einen sehr großen Teil der ganzen Emissionen durch Landnutzung und Landnutzungsänderungen verursachen, das lässt sich kaum verstehen. Weil man nicht versteht, dass es so ein kondensiertes und konzentriertes Problem ist. Wie gesagt, 4% der Landfläche der Erde sind entwässerte Moore.
85% der Moore der Welt sind noch heile. Und doch verursacht dieses kleine Zeug, wenn wir es richtig betrachten, diese Probleme. Wenn wir sehen, was in den Tropen tätig ist mit dieser Abforstung. Das ist natürlich viel schrecklicher. Da sieht man etwas schönes, was kaputt gemacht wird. Beim Moor hat man immer die Idee gehabt, das ist ein Sumpf. Das hat natürlich eine sehr negative Grundhaltung. Wenn man Bücher liest, du sagst sofort Moorleiche, warum Moorleiche? Es gibt kaum Moorleichen von Menschen, die selbstständig ins Moor gekommen sind. Alle Moorleichen, fast alle, sind dort reingebracht worden. Da hat man Leute exekutiert, das sind vorher ermordete Menschen, die man dort beerdigt hat, dass sie nicht mehr rauskommen würden. Die sind nicht im Moor versunken selbst, die sind versenkt worden. Mit einem Schlitz im Nacken oder weiß ich nicht, das sind die Moorleichen, die wir haben.
Das ist schon von den Römern beschrieben. Dasidus (???) hat das glaube ich schon beschrieben, dass hier die Homosexuellen getötet wurden und in den Sumpf geschmissen. Und die finden wir jetzt als Moorleiche. Aber wir haben grundsätzlich und das hat bestimmt auch zu tun mit unserer Halbwüsten-Herkunft und unserer Landwirtschaft und unseren Genen auch. Weil es ist nachgewiesen, dass mit der Verbreitung der Landwirtschaft nicht nur die Kultur und die Technik sich verbreitet haben. Aber auch die Gene, es sind die Menschen. Wir haben hier in Westeuropa sehr viel Gene mit dem Osten. Die sind mit der Landwirtschaft reingekommen. Wir haben diese Geringschätzung von Sümpfen einfach in uns. Und wir sehen in fast allen Kulturen, dass Sümpfe sehr negativ belegt werden. Wenn irgendwo ein Sumpf umgebaut wird in schöne grüne Wiese mit üppigem Gras und voller Kühe und so weiter, dann sieht man das als positiv.
Wenn man das gleiche in den Tropen tut, weil man ein natürliches System, einen tropischen Regenwald, umhackt und dort Ölpalmen, hochproduktives Gewächs aufsetzt, dann sieht man das als einen riesigen Verlust, obwohl das eigentlich ähnliche Prozesse sind. Die negative Einschätzung, Grundeinschätzung von Mooren hat natürlich auch verhindert, zusammen mit der Kleinheit von Mooren, dass es richtig nach vorne gekommen ist. Da kommt noch dazu, dass diese Moore immer auch als Komplex gesehen werden. Bei Wäldern redet man nur über CO2-Festlegung. Bei Mooren redet man immer auch von Methan. Wenn man über Moore redet, kommt sofort Methan. Methan ist das stärkste Treibhausgas. Da ist auch etwas böses aus Klimasicht dran an Mooren.
Und deshalb haben die gesagt, ja wenn man schon mehr als ein Gas hat, dann ist es schon komplex, weil das gegeneinander läuft. Wenn ein lebendes Moor hat, das speichert, das legt zwar CO2 fest, aber weil es nur CO2 festlegen kann unter wassergesättigten Bedingungen, anaerobe Bedingungen, tritt unausweichbar auch Methanerzeugung auf. So lebende Moore emittieren auch Methan. Mengenmäßig viel geringer als was sie an CO2 festlegen, aber weil Methan ein Treibhauspotenzial hat, was 25-30mal größer ist als CO2, sind die kleinen Mengen so bedeutsam, dass sie eigentlich den Klimaeffekt von der CO2-Festlegun neutralisieren. Die lebenden Moore auf der Erde, wenn man das auf diese betrachtet, das hat auch mit der Zeit zu tun, haben eigentlich keinen Effekt auf das Klima.
Weil die Festlegung von CO2 ist genauso groß, seine Klimawirkung, wie die Ausstöße von Methan. Nur ganz langfristig, weil Methan eine viel kürzere Verweilzeit hat in der Atmosphäre und nach 12-14 Jahren schon umgesetzt ist in CO2, kriegt man eigentlich die Situation, dass langfristig Moore tatsächlich das Klima kühlen. Und das auch schon 11.000 Jahre tun. Aber wenn man es berechnet nach den Maßstäben, wie man alle Emissionen berechnet, sind lebende Moore eigentlich klimaneutral. Sie werden nur sehr klimabelastend, wenn man sie entwässert und dieses CO2 anjagt. Und dies sind dann solch komplexe Geschichten, dass für die Zielsetzung und Evaluierung und Berichterstattung, Monitoring in der Klimakonvention, das schon schnell zu kompliziert wird.
Man hat in der Klimakonvention angefangen mit einfachen Regeln und einfachen Lösungen, erst mal das einfachste. Und jetzt sieht man, dass man, nachdem man mehr nachgedacht hat und mehr inventarisiert hat, sagt, ja wir können auch komplexere Sachen tun und jetzt kann man tatsächlich auch die Moore reinbringen und das ist dann auch geschehen.
Ist ganz interessant. Also es gibt ja, um den Blick von der Erde mal wegzunehmen, wir haben ja einen Nachbarplaneten, die Venus, die dafür bekannt ist, eine total feindliche Atmosphäre zu haben, so der totale Treibhausgas-Overkill. Hunderte Grad in der Atmosphäre, dort findet alles das statt, was man hier auf gar keinen Fall haben möchte. Wenn man sich anguckt, wie sich das jetzt so entwickelt hat aus den Erzählungen, die ich jetzt hier so mitnehme, sehe ich, dass die Moore eigentlich dazu beigetragen haben, über einen sehr langen Zeitraum CO2 aus der Atmosphäre abzuziehen. Es wurde erst in Pflanzen umgewandelt, aber es wurde dann eben nicht in so einem normalen Prozess wieder zurückgegeben, sondern es wurde einfach eingelagert. Es ist in diesen Mooren einfach versiegelt und hat einfach die Gesamtmenge dieses Gases so stark reduziert. Und damit, unter Umständen, auch dazu beigetragen, dass wir überhaupt so ein ausgeglichenes Klima haben.
Und in dem Moment, wo wir jetzt quasi ein Moor trockenlegen ist es so ein bisschen die Büchse der Pandora, wenn man das irgendwie aufmacht, schießt all das über Jahrhunderte, Jahrtausende gespeicherte Material einfach wieder zurück und wird an der Stelle zu einem Problem.
Ja auf große Zeiträume gesehen geht man davon aus, dass die Moorbildung, die dann zur Kohlefestlegung geführt hat und Braunkohle, dass die tatsächlich maßgeblich die CO2-Konzentration in der Atmosphäre zurück gebracht hat. Es ist auch so, dass im Karbon, wo diese Steinkohlmoore entstanden sind, die Torfbildung auch viel üppiger war und viel schneller ging wahrscheinlich, einfach weil die CO2-Konzentration höher war. Wir sehen das jetzt auch schon, dass durch die erhöhte CO2-Konzentration in der Luft, durch diese CO2-Ausstöße, dass dadurch die Pflanzen, die Wälder und auch die Moore schneller wachsen. Das ist CO2-Düngung. Das machen wir in den Niederlanden auch, in den Treibhäusern in den Niederlanden wird Erdgas verbrannt nicht für die Wärme, aber um CO2 zu erzeugen. Wir haben da ein Verb dafür, das heißt CO2en.
Weil die Produktivität von Tomaten nimmt dadurch so zu, dass man extra Geld damit verdienen kann. Die Tomate, die man in Deutschland kauft, die aus den Niederlanden kommen, die sind zum Teil durch fossile, also sind zum Teil fossile Rohstoffe, weil die sind gewachsen auf fossilem CO2. Aber das zeigt den Effekt. Wir haben so verdammt wenig CO2 in der Atmosphäre. Diese 0,xxx 400 BPM momentan. Das ist so unglaublich wenig. Wenn man das erhöht, dann nimmt richtig die Produktivität zu. Und das ist auch einer der Gründe, dass man so viele Steinkohlenablagerungen hat, weil das CO2 in der Atmosphäre damals viel höher war. Und es gibt auch eine seriöse Theorie, die sagt, dass auch diese Eiszeiten, die wir gehabt haben hier in den letzten Millionen Jahren, dass die maßgeblich mitgelenkt sind durch die Torfbildung.
Dass man zwischen den Eiszeiten so viel Kohlenstoff festlegt, dass der CO2-Gehalt in der Atmosphäre beträchtlich runtergeht und den Treibhausgaseffekt durch CO2 verringert, wodurch man die Eiszeiten einlädt. Da gibt es natürlich die ganze Bilankowicz (???), Tschikli (???) Und so weiter, diese komplexe Sache, wie die Sonne und die Erde umeinanderdrehen und die Sonne die Erde bestrahlt. Aber dass darauf die Verringerung des CO2-Gehalts in der Atmosphäre wichtig ist, um überhaupt diese Eiszeiten anfangen zu lassen. Weil die Menge Kohlenstoff, die in unseren Mooren sitzt auf der Erde, die nach der Eiszeit entstanden ist, entspricht etwa 75% des Kohlenstoffs in der Atmosphäre. Da kann ich einfach so sagen, wenn wir das freisetzen würden, würde die Konzentration in der Atmosphäre verdoppelt oder wir haben natürlich auch die Senke im Ozean und so weiter. Aber es gibt einfach an, dass doch wohl eine verdammt große Bande an Kohlenstoff in diesen Mooren festliegt.
Das heißt in dem Moment, wo Moore jetzt auch wieder verwässert werden würden, also neu mit Wasser bedeckt werden würden und damit im Prinzip ja auch dieser Moorprozess, dass also Pflanzen, die dort wachsen, auch diesem Moor sich wieder versenken, wenn dieser Prozess wieder angestoßen wird, zumindest ein Stück weit, dass jetzt, wo quasi verhältnismäßig viel CO2 in der Atmosphäre ist, zumindest zu der Situation vor 50 Jahren, die Moore auch sehr viel aktiver sozusagen CO2 versenken würden?
Ja wie gesagt diese CO2-Senke von Mooren ist langfristig wohl bedeutsam, aber kurzfristig eigentlich kaum. Alle Moore der Welt, die jetzt noch leben, 85% immerhin, 3,5 Millionen m² oder so etwas, die speichern, die versenken jährlich etwa so 1% von allen Emissionen aus fossilen Brennstoffen. Die Moore werden die Welt in dieser Hinsicht nicht retten.
Zumindest nicht kurzfristig.
Da können wir strategisch unsere Sache nicht… Die Moore werden das Problem der Verringerung nicht lösen. Was wir wohl tun können ist, die CO2-Konzentration in der Atmosphäre verringern, dadurch dass wir den Ausstoß bremsen oder vollständig anhalten durch die Wiedervernässung. Man war eigentlich ein neutrales System, das vollständig mobilisiert zu riesigen Emissionen von 30 Tonnen bis hin zu 60-80 Tonnen CO2 äquivalent Hektar pro Jahr führt. Was jetzt ausgestoßen ist. Und das kann man wieder zurückdrängen durch diese Wiedervernässung.
Was mich jetzt so zum Schluss nochmal interessieren würde, bist ja da in verschiedenen Organisationen auch mit dabei, beim Weltklimarat, dem IPCC, der im wesentlichen jetzt für diesen Klimabericht und die Planung oder für die Empfehlung was in Zukunft denn getan werden sollte verantwortlich ist, auch in der Welternährungsorganisation, in der FAO. In der UN, in verschiedenen Gruppen, und konkret gibt es ja auch noch diese International-Mire-Conservation-Group, also die sich jetzt konkret um die Sümpfe, die Moore kümmert. Wie muss man diesen Prozess der wissenschaftspolitischen Arbeit sich anschauen? Also wie gut kommt man in diesen Organisationen voran?
Ist es schwierig, dort Gehör zu finden? Ist es schwierig, dort Dinge zu verändern? Welche politische Arbeit ist hier erforderlich, um dort Fortschritte zu erzielen? Unabhängig jetzt von der eigentlichen wissenschaftlichen Arbeit?
Das ist ziemlich schwierig. Ich habe selbst maßgeblich daran gearbeitet, dass im neuen Kyoto-Protokoll zwei Sätze stehen, die mit Mooren zu tun haben. Das hat mich 150 Tage aktive Verhandlung gekostet und 300.000 Euro an Geld, neben allem was nicht direkt während der Verhandlungen wo die stattgefunden haben, Lima …
Also Reisekosten und so weiter.
Das illustriert das einigermaßen. Es ist sehr schwierig in Klimakonventionen etwas zu ändern. Das ist auch die Frustration von vielen, dass man zu wenig vorankommt. Wir haben natürlich mit Paris einen Riesenschritt gesetzt, aber es muss implementiert werden und das kostet auch Zeit. Alles kostet unglaublich viel Zeit. Das hat seine großen Nachteile, aber ich denke, dass es auch nicht anders kann oder sehr schwierig. Weil diese Entscheidungen, die dort genommen werden, zum Beispiel in der Klimakonvention oder bei FAO oder wo dann auch, haben natürlich ihre Auswirkung über die ganze Welt. Ich bekam vor einigen Wochen eine E-Mail aus Amerika von Jason Frank, der ist ein sehr aktiver in der ganzen Waldklimaverhandlungen gewesen.
Der ist auch der offizielle Vertreter gewesen von Gabun In der Klimakonvention und der sagt, Mensch ich lese jetzt hier ein Regierungsdokument der Vereinigten Staaten, worin festgelegt steht, dass die in den kommenden Jahren Moore wieder vernassen gehen. Er sagt, wenn ihr noch jemals dran zweifelt, ob ihr etwas erreicht habt im Leben, lest dieses Ding. Weil ihr habt richtig grundsätzliche Sachen geändert. Und das sind natürlich nur kleine Sachen, die man in Weltkonventionen ändert, aber die sind richtungsgebend für alle Länder und alle Regierungen und die tricklen durch die ganzen Ketten der Institutionen durch, werden umgesetzt in Gesetzgebung, in Programmen, in Projekte und so weiter, in Geldströmen und das hat große Konsequenzen. Das haben die Leute, die sich mit Forst beschäftigt haben, die haben gesagt, das Kyoto-Protokoll hat weltweit die Forstwirtschaft geändert.
Und so wird das auch mit Mooren sein. Das ist sehr schwierig, das zu beurteilen. Ich denke, dass wir im weitesten Sinne es geschafft haben in den letzten zehn Jahren, die Moore in die Pictures zu spielen und ihnen die Anerkennung zu geben, die sie verdienen. Die wurden früher vollständig vernachlässigt, wir nannten das das Cinderella-Syndrom, das Aschenputtel-Syndrom, etwas was ganz wichtig ist, aber nicht berücksichtigt wird. Wir haben die Moore etwas bekannter gemacht und ihre enorme Bedeutung und ihre Herausforderungen klarer gemacht. Und jetzt ist es auch so, dass in der Klimakonvention über Moore geredet wird, auch wenn ich nicht da bin. Früher war ich der einzige, der über Moore geredet hat.
Ach da ist wieder der mit den Mooren.
Erst wurde nur über Moore geredet, wenn ich da war, weil ich war der einzige, der über Moore redete. Dann hat es eine Phase gegeben, dass über Moore geredet wurde, wenn ich dabei war, dann wurde man an Moore erinnert, wenn man meinen Kopf gesehen hat sozusagen. Ich war offizieller Verhandler dort, ich konnte in all diese internen Verhandlungen reinkommen. Wenn man dann da sitzt, dann hat man mich angeguckt und hat gesagt, oh ja wir dürfen die Moore nicht vergessen. Weil das ist dann natürlich auch eine Erkennung. Wir haben im Rahmen dieser Prozesse sehr viel wissenschaftlich aufgearbeitet. Das war eigentlich ein ganz spannender Ping-Pong-Prozess. In diesen Verhandlungen hört man dann – das sind abgeschottete Verhandlungen – hört man dann, was die Besorgnisse sind oder die unausgesprochenen politischen Programme von unterschiedlichen Ländern. Und dann sieht man, dass man bestimmte Sachen, die man nicht wünscht politisch, versucht zu motivieren mittels pseudowissenschaftlichen Aussagen.
Zum Beispiel Methan, weil wir darüber gesprochen hatten, Klimakonvention und IPCC haben ganz lange Methan außen vor gehalten. Und auch in den Mooren eigentlich die Moore rauslassen wollen wegen dem Methan, weil Methan ist vor allem eine Bedrohung für Länder, die große Hydroelektrizitätzentralen machen in den Tropen.
Was genau machen?
So Fläche fluten für Hydroelektrizitätsgewinnung. Zum Beispiel in den Amazonen werden riesige Flächen jetzt geflutet, gestaut für Energiegewinnung. Umweltfreundliche Energiegewinnung.
Also Stauseen, Dämme.
Stauseen. Diese Stauseen in den flachen Bereichen und die besten Bereiche mit steilen Hängen sind schon ausgewählt überall in der Welt. Man geht jetzt in die flachen Bereiche, wo ein Stausee riesige Oberflächen einnimmt. Das bedeutet einfach, dass in trockenen Zeiten diese Stauseen weitgehend trockenfallen, dass die dann in tropische Gebiete rasch besiedelt werden mit frischer Vegetation und das nächste halbe Jahr steigt der Stausee an und die ganze frische Biomasse wird geflutet. Was man dort generiert sind Methangeneratoren ohne Vergleich. Und Länder wie Brasilien wissen das, und ich denke, dass das einer der Gründe gewesen ist, dass man immer versucht hat, Methan aus der Klimakonvention möglichst weitgehend raus zu halten. Und auch der IPCC und so weiter.
Und deshalb wurde Methan sofort auch als großes Problem gesehen, wenn wir die Moore in die Diskussionen gebracht haben. Dann haben wir darauf reagiert durch sofort das nächste halbe Jahr erst wissenschaftliche Berichte, aber nachher auch seriöse wissenschaftliche Publikationen zu machen, wo wir das Problem mal skizzieren und sagen, ja tatsächlich, wenn man ein Moor wieder vernässt, kriegst du einen Extraausstoß von 10 Tonnen CO2-equvalent an Methan. Aber gleichzeitig reduzierst du den CO2-Ausstoß mit 25 Tonnen. So dann hast du einen Gewinn von 15 Tonnen. Du musst nicht nur auf das Methan gucken, sondern auf das ganze Bild. Und diese Sache, wenn dann das Methan politisch eingebracht würde, um überhaupt das außen vor zu lassen, sind wir dauernd gekommen Publikationen und haben gesagt, so steckt das ineinander.
Die Frage, können wir überhaupt monitoren, wenn wir Moore wieder vernässen, dass eine Reduktion von Emissionen stattfindet? Wie tut man das? Wenn wir über Treibhausgase reden, dann reden wir über gebackene Luft. Wie können wir sehen, ob eine Emission stattfindet? Bei einer Industrie ist das einfach, da weißt du, so viele Kohlen verbrennen wir. Man wiegt vorher die Kohle und das wird alles CO2. Wie tut man das mit einem Moor? Können wir das monitoring reporting and verifying. Du kannst wohl sagen, dass es so ist, du kannst es wohl berichten …
Aber man kann es nicht messen.
… Aber kann das von unabhängigen Leuten auch verifiziert werden? Und das ist natürlich die Grundlage von Vertrauen, was man haben muss.
Geht das?
Ja das geht. Dann haben wir gesagt, es gibt diese und diese Methode, um es zu tun. Man kann es messen. Das Messen ist zu teuer. Das Messen ist einfach zu teuer. Wenn man eine Gasmessung machen will auf einem Hektar Moor langfristig, das kostet 10.000 Euro pro Hektar pro Jahr. Viel zu teuer. Man muss, was dann nennt "Proxies" entwickeln. Proxies heißt Indikatoren. Etwas anderes, was diese Sache andeutet. Und das haben wir auch ganz entwickelt. Wir haben sogenannte Gest-System entwickelt - Greenhousegas Emission Side Types -  weil wir wissen, dass Vegetation ein sehr guter Indikator ist für Wasserstand. Wir haben Feuchtgebietspflanze und manche wachsen sehr feucht und andere nicht. Die kann man einordnen. Außerdem sind Pflanzen selbst auch verantwortlich für Emissionen. Sie produzieren, wie man das nennt, Wurzelexudaten, die stoßen Substanzen aus mit ihren Wurzeln.
Was oft die Grundlage ist für die Bildung von Methan und so weiter. Außerdem haben Feuchtgebietspflanzen Aerenchyme, um Sauerstoff in ihre Wurzeln zu kriegen, aber die funktionieren als Schornsteine für Methan, um von tief aus dem anaeroben Bereich direkt in die Atmosphäre zu kommen. Wir können an bestimmten Pflanzen, wenn die irgendwo wachsen, die Methanemission verdoppeln. Einfach weil mehr Methan durch den Schornstein geht und weniger durch die Oberfläche dringt, wo die dann in der obersten Schicht, wo es keine Wassersättigung gibt, oxidiert wird. Und so haben wir ein ganzes System entwickelt, dass, wenn wir die Vegetation kartieren, wir sofort auch sagen können, wie viel sind die Emissionen dort. Und das ist ein viel billigeres Verfahren, das kann man handmäßig machen. Aber wir haben das auch mit Remote Sensig, mit Satellitenbildern, auch dass man das automatisieren kann, dass man das monitoren kann.
Man muss auch diese Methode entwickeln. Man kann wohl sagen, politisch ist es wichtig, dass Moore wieder vernässt werden und dass das mit verrechnet werden kann, aber andererseits muss man es messen können, verifizieren können, sonst funktioniert es nicht. Und diese Methoden müssen wissenschaftlich entwickelt werden.
Und ist das dann so, wenn man mit solchen Methoden dann ankommt, dass dann auch alle gleich die Hände in die Luft werfen und sagen, oh super, das hat uns jetzt noch gefehlt, das machen wir jetzt noch? Oder ist das nicht noch von einer längeren Phase der Skepsis und des Aushandelns geprägt?
Natürlich. Und das muss es auch geben. Ich kann mir die Katastrophe nicht vorstellen, was geschehen würde, wenn jede geniale Idee in der Welt sofort umgesetzt würde. Weil die meisten genialen Ideen sind überhaupt nicht genial. Die haben solche schlechten Nebeneffekte. Das sind meistens Teillösungen für Teilprobleme, die irgendwo anders noch viel viel größere Probleme machen. So dass es dauert und dass es kritisch betrachtet wird, aus welchem Grund dann auch, dass man gezwungen wird, das zu überdenken. Wir spielen hier mit dem Weltklima. Das ist eine der meist dominanten Sachen, wo man mit spielen kann. Dann muss man nicht über ein Nachteis (???) gehen. Und das ist natürlich der große Konflikt, den wir haben, dass wir eigentlich sehr schnell auftreten müssen, aber dass wir auch mit etwas so grundlegendem arbeiten, dass wir es uns eigentlich nicht leisten können, Fehler zu machen. Und ich kann auch eine ganz begeisternde Geschichte über Moore erzählen, aber man muss nicht alles glauben.
Man muss das natürlich testen, testen, testen, testen. Und wir müssen irgendwo das Mittelfeld finden, dass wir tatsächlich schnell vorankommen, aber doch auf Basis von guten Fakten und auch mit einer breiten Sicht. Weil was hier geschieht kann irgendwo anders oder später einen anderen Effekt haben.
Ist denn dieses Gremien IPCC, was sich ja aus vielen Wissenschaftlern zusammensetzt, aber eben auch diese politische Komponente jetzt eben mit dazu bekommt, ist das für einen Wissenschaftler noch wissenschaftlich genug, wie dort gearbeitet wird? Ist das im Prinzip so eine Art neue Form, dass man sagt, okay vorher gab es die wissenschaftliche Methode, jetzt gibt es vielleicht die wissenschaftlich-politische Methode, die wir so eigentlich in dem Maße bisher noch gar nicht gehabt haben? Oder kippt es so sehr in die Politik, dass es mit dem wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten nichts mehr zu tun hat?
Irgendwie muss vermittelt werden zwischen Wissenschaft und Gesellschaft und politischen Entscheidungen. Viele Wissenschaftler denken, dass ihre Ergebnisse zu publizieren ausreicht. Dass die dann durchdringen zur Politik, das ist natürlich nicht so. Es wird einfach zu viel gemacht. Politik steht wenig offen für Sachen, wo sie selbst sich nicht mit beschäftigen. Man muss erst eine politische Agenda haben, bevor politische interessiert sind in wissenschaftliche Fakten, die mit dieser Agenda zu tun haben. Dann können Wissenschaftler natürlich gut Einfluss … Naja nein, Fakten anliefern für die Politik.
Und das ist auch eine wichtige Aufgabe, das muss auf bestimmte Weise aufbereitet sein. Weil die wissenschaftliche Sprache, die Weise auf der man publiziert eignet sich eigentlich nicht für Politiker. Man kann sich kaum vorstellen, und ich habe doch wohl irgendwo Bewunderung für die Politiker, ich schimpfe natürlich viel drauf, aber das sind doch wohl Menschen, die sehr viel gleichzeitig abwägen müssen. Und wo du fünf Jahre gearbeitet hast an einer Publikation und die dann wissenschaftlich so "condensed" geschrieben hast, dass nur noch drei andere Leute der Welt die lesen können, die Politiker müssen eigentlich all diese Tatsachen auf einer DIN A4 Seite aufnehmen, weil es gibt neben dieser Sache noch tausend andere Sachen, die sie integriert betrachten müssen. Man muss als Wissenschaftler auch die Daten auf eine Weise aufarbeiten, dass man auf den Punkt kommt.
Das ist vereinfacht, und vereinfacht ist immer unvollständig. Aber die Vollständigkeit verhindert, dass man es vermitteln kann und die gute Vereinfachung ist nur möglich, wenn man das ganz gut versteht. Man muss erst ein Buch von 1000 Seiten schreiben, bevor man die wesentliche Botschaft in einer Seite zusammenfassen kann. In diesen 1000 Seiten musst abwägen, was richtig relevant ist, was ist die richtige Botschaft? Wo geh ich die Sache ablenken vom Hauptziel, wo gehe ich Sachen sagen, die vielleicht aus anderen Arbeiten kommen. Das müssen natürlich Wissenschaftler tun, aber irgendwo muss das dann zusammengefasst werden. Und IPCC macht in ihren Grundberichten natürlich diesen Prozess, die 1000 Seiten schreiben. Das ist schon eine sehr große Integration. Und dann hat man dann die politische Zusammenfassung von diesen Rapporten, das ist dann nochmals zusammengeschmolzen.
Ich denke, dass Wissenschaftler durch Anliefern von guten Fakten eine richtige Auswirkung haben können auf die Entscheidungen, die genommen werden. Aber dann muss es klar dargestellt werden und verständlich. Das ist für Wissenschaftler oft vielleicht unbefriedigend, aber es geht nicht anders, denke ich. Und man muss natürlich durch anzuhalten, aber das ist letztendlich auch eine politische Aktivität, die nicht so sehr von Wissenschaftlern gemacht wird, aber mehr von Interessengruppen, muss man versuchen,  bestimmte Sachen auf die Agenda zu kriegen, das ist tatsächlich ein politisches Item wert. Weil die Politik wird sich nicht für die Wissenschaft interessieren, wenn es kein politisches Item ist.
Wissenschaft kann sehr schwierig ein politisches Item kreieren, das geht oft via Interessengruppen, politische Parteien und so weiter, die dann, wenn es ein richtiges Problem ist, auch selbst Sachen, die kein richtiges Problem sind, auch auf die politische Agenda kriegen. Und dann hat man die Möglichkeit, auch bessere wissenschaftliche Informationen in politische Entscheidungsprozesse einzufüttern.
Ich frage mich, kann man diese politische Komponente des wissenschaftlichen Arbeitens, wie kann man die lernen oder wie kann man sie vielleicht auch lehren? Ist es überhaupt erforderlich? Wäre es angemessen, das quasi als Teil eines wissenschaftlichen Ausbildungsprozesses mitzudenken. Zumindest in einem kleinen Aspekt?
Ja das ist eine Frage, die hat mehrere Seiten. Wir haben natürlich die größten Erfolge der Wissenschaft liegen in der Beschränkung der Wissenschaft. Zerteilen der Welt in ganze kleine Wäldchen, wo man dann ganz tief reingeht. Das bringt die Kenntnisse richtig voran. Dass man damit Leute kreiert, die nicht mehr anständig kommunizieren können mit einer normalen Welt, ist eine logische Folge. Aber solche Leute braucht man auch, braucht man. Aber daneben braucht man auch Leute, die mit diesen Spezialisten reden können und dieses einbauen können in breitere Wissenschaft. Und vielleicht braucht man dann auch wieder eine Gruppe von Leuten, die das dann vermitteln können mit politischem.
Die wissen, wie die ticken, was für Fragen die stellen, was auf der Agenda steht und dann diese wissenschaftliche Aufarbeitungen einfüttern können. Diese Tiefgeher werden niemals in der Lage sein, mit Politik zu kommunizieren. Man braucht sie für die Wissenschaft, aber sie können nicht kommunizieren, da bin ich von überzeugt. Und dann ist die Frage, muss man die Tiefgeher auch alle lehren zu kommunizieren? Ist die Frage, ich würde darin nicht investieren. Lasst die tiefgehen und lasst die kommunizieren mit der nächsten Stufe im Vermittlungsprozess, die etwas höhere Integration. Dass man daneben tatsächlich diese Integratoren lernen oder lehren muss, wie man etwas politisch aufbereitet und wie man etwas auf die politische Agenda kriegt, das ist natürlich notwendig. Ich denke nicht, dass es notwendig ist, dass jeder Wissenschaftler politisch reden kann.
Also mittelfristig ist es eher wichtig, dass man quasi ein neues Betätigungsfeld auftut. Dass Leute, die sich dort berufen fühlen, vielleicht diese Art von Wissenschaftslobbyismus stärker in den Fokus nehmen. So wie Wissenschaftskommunikation und Wissenschaftsmanagement auch langsam so zu eigenen Feldern werden, die so vielleicht vorher noch nie gesehen wurden, weil man sich halt immer schön in seinem stillen Kämmerlein verschränkt hat und jetzt kommen diese Disziplinen auch mit zum tragen.
Ich habe in dieser ganzen Klimasache sehr eng zusammengearbeitet mit einer Kommunikationsspezialistin von Wetland International. Und das war eigentlich ein ideales Team fand ich, so mit unseren Teams umher. Weil sie wusste, wie man kommuniziert. Natürlich kann ich das auch lernen, aber ich kann das nur lernen, wenn ich andere Sachen nicht lerne. Ich habe auch nur einen beschränkten Kopf. Und das ist natürlich die Kunst, dass man Teams macht von Leuten, die doch miteinander kommunizieren können, mit eigenen Spezialitäten. Und sie hatte keine Ahnung von Mooren, das brauchte sie auch nicht, weil die hatte ich schon, aber ich hatte keine Ahnung vom Kommunizieren. Das machte sie dann. Aber diese Zusammenarbeit ist sehr erfolgreich. Und nur durch diese Zusammenarbeit denke ich, dass es so erfolgreich gewesen ist. Das sehe ich ganz klar.
Also sowohl interdisziplinäre Forschung, aber in diesem Fall vor allem auch so eine heterogene Teambildung, um einfach auch in den Ergebnissen politisch schlagkräftig zu sein, das könnte zum Ziel führen?
Dass man die Daten, die man hat, auch da kriegt, wo man sie braucht. Selbst wenn die Leute das selbst noch nicht wissen.
Hans Joosten, ich sage vielen Dank, das war eine tolle Reise durch die Moore. Wo mir auch selber viel klar geworden ist, was ich so noch nie gesehen habe. Wenn man es sich dann im Detail anschaut, dann wirkt es immer so selbstverständlich, wenn man diese Erkenntnisse erst mal gehabt hat, aber dazu ist eben ein sehr viel genauerer Forschungsblick und Forschergeist auch erforderlich, der hat sich hier deutlich gezeigt. Vielen Dank.
Gern gemacht.
Vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Das war die 28. Ausgabe und natürlich geht es auch bald weiter mit anderen interessanten Themen. Bis dahin sage ich erst mal, tschüss und bis bald.